hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast standardized precision
medicine equality management perspective
on NGS based individualized therapies is
presented by Christoph and Lola who is
an independent freelancer I am Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
anytime you want during the presentation
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box it appears on the screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located any promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
christoph andrew lot i will now turn the
presentation over to him okay so welcome
everyone
i christoph and rod and i want to say
it's a great honor for me to give a
presentation here on left roots in front
of the screens around the globe often
worldwide audience so i happy to share
my experience and my expertise with you
i will talk today about precision
medicine and from a standardized point
of view so standardization which plays a
pivotal role in a lot of industries
nowadays and the application of stand
harmonization and precision medicine so
I will give you quality management
perspective on NGS based individualized
therapies mmm
so as I have the honor to be the first
presenter today I want to go in a little
discourse on precision medicine so what
does precision medicine means what are
the benefits of it at first
individualization right so
individualized treatments for
individualized patients which means
tailor treatments so more than one size
fit all treatments it's more tailored
for the unique patient itself and one
great benefit of this precision medicine
approach is we have better response
rates we have fewer adverse events we
are able to monitor and serve real
resistance mechanisms doing a therapy
and also one general aspect we precision
medicine offers reduced costs for the
healthcare system itself
hmm I will go more into detail during my
presentation but what I want to tell you
before this is very interesting in my
opinion AHS because I always confuse
precision medicine and personalized
medicine I thought that's a common term
so both I used equal but actually that's
not precision medicine is not equal to
personalized medicine according to the
NIH personalized medicine apply is a
unique treatment for each individual so
one single patient one single treatment
but precision medicine means effective
approaches for different patients based
on their genetic profile their
environment and also their lifestyle so
it's rather detailed or more strong
patient stratification than a unit
treatment at the moment and precision
medicine is needed it's time to do this
so in in nowadays
still patients receive chemotherapy
either they are benefiting or they are
not benefiting they have adverse events
and therefore it's time to make a change
in this field I put a nice picture here
which I really like this picture shows
an appliance for measuring the feet size
so if you want to buy shoes you get a
personalized approach for buying these
shoes your feet gets measured though
with the length so and this is quite
confusing actually because for food size
for it
buying shoes we have a more personalized
approach than currently in medicine this
is an interesting thing thought in my
opinion so and this is what we have
actually one size does not fit all
according to the shoes large shoes will
not fit for a smaller person and the
other way around and that's the same
with personalized medicine also with
sweets a business sweets like on this
picture we have this little boy wearing
way too much or too too big sweet so and
that this has to be transformed into
this so the sweet which is not fitting
for this little boy has to be tailored
that it's fitting and this is the way we
want to transform the medicine today
from the left side to the right side and
how does this will be accomplished by
standardization and harmonization
crucial parts and I will go into the
more detail later on but before some
little bit more is caused on precision
medicine there was a study done by a
PricewaterhouseCoopers the strategy and
consultants and they asked different
precision medicine stakeholders about
the expected benefits the along the
pharma value chain and those respondents
were asked to select up to five options
from research development market
authorization and post product launch
and it's interesting what the
stakeholders responded to the study in
the research area most respondents see
as a benefit the identification of new
drug targets for the tail treatments and
the development sections the
stakeholders see more convincing data
outcomes of clinical trials also more
effective and efficient clinical trials
in the market authorization the
stakeholders see as one of the biggest
benefits clarity around the target
patient profile and also an increasing
competitive advantage and finally in a
post product launch the stakeholders
shared opinion yet improve outcomes
throughout the continuous therapy are
achieved so which means for example
monitoring of patient response but how
our precision medicine is performed we
need metrics we need benchmarks in
precision precision medicine and there I
come to the team or to determine of the
biomarkers biomarkers are rapidly
expanding in precision medicine and the
idea behind is we have a patient
population let's see it on the right
picture we have different patients and
at first a tumor subtyping is performed
that we get a better patient
stratification then we have different
patient populations with different tumor
subtypes and then we can analyze those
patients according to subtype specific
prognostic biomarkers and then we have a
much more detailed patient
stratification and we can distinguish
between patients who will benefit or
will not benefit according to their
biomarker profile and there's already a
remarkable biomarker landscape we have
established biomarkers like the ALK and
non source non-small-cell lung cancer we
have the ross one also an NSERC we have
eg of our and NSC SC colorectal
carcinoma and also specific form of the
breast cancer we have the hair too which
is also quite old and famous biomarker
in breast cancer we have cement in HTF
in NSC SC and different cancer types
with the Kira's in EM CRC also lung
cancer and also the brca1 and brca2 and
breast cancer and ovarian cancer but
this lists not intended to be complete
there there are more biomarkers which
are established just given overview one
really strongly accelerating field in
the biomarker research are the immuno
ecology biomarkers the i/o biomarkers as
we know there are a lot of in oncology
treatments which have a strong impact on
clinical practice and also also in
patient benefits and there was a study
which was performed by Dave C bio
consulting so decisive Biosciences they
performed study where they have taken
data from clinical trials and analyze
those data for example which biomarkers
were analyzed within clinical trials and
they have analyzed 1,000 ontology
clinical trials and they have identified
more than 1200 biomarkers from which 90%
are IO specific and this is a really
nice figure here on the right you can
see the number of trials and also
approach molecular type they are the
biomarkers either protein or nucleic
acids or cells and the width of the
circle they are corresponds to the
number of trials which are performed and
here in the middle which catches your
eye can see PDL one typical typical in
oncology biomarker where a lot of
treatments the upcoming immune
checkpoint inhibitors are aiming it so
we have a huge amount of clinical trials
but also you can see her to the site in
profile
estrogen receptor for breast cancer and
also a lot of different a lot of several
others and those are also all the
next-generation new biomarkers they also
called next-gen io biomarkers and we can
differentiate between the most explored
predictive biomarkers currently those
are two more infra tape infiltrating
like you see it's the PD one the TMB
this is the tumor mutational burn which
plays a pivotal role especially in NGS
which I will come to later on also
peripheral blood moons population and
gene expression signatures then we have
also the most explored response
monitoring biomarkers so once patient
receive precision treatment the response
can be surveilled by Diagnostics
and also when mutations of pure due to
the treatment this can be detected and
therefore the most explosive response
monitoring biomarkers of the peripheral
blood immune cell population gene
expressions and also the cytokine
profiles and now finally the fastest
evolving bio oxalá biomarkers which will
play pi water role in the future those
are a first CTC there also the tumor
infiltrating electric suits pd-1 and the
ligand PDL one for immune oncology
treatments and the genomic signatures
again so two moment a tional burden and
MSI the microsatellite instability so
these are genomic or molecular profiling
biomarkers for future advancements in
precision medicine so but how are these
biomarkers are detected or their mind
their account Dom of Diagnostics
diagnostic they are the crucial part
within a precision medicine approach in
order to determine the biomarkers in
order to give a result about presence or
absence of an biomarker also the
quantity the quantity plays a role and
also the quality assured analysis
regarding samples the technology
platforms and applied procedures and
here on the right you can see typical
Diagnostics of biomarkers is performed
by pathologists there's a very nice
picture from a breast cancer which was
colored with a dye and can see different
biomarkers there's pictures for example
the estrogen receptor the progress roan
receptor also EGFR all crucial
biomarkers which are relevant for the
diagnosis and also the continuing
treatment in this case for breast cancer
and this now Diagnostics is a different
term from companion diagnostics because
companion diagnostics those are the
dykes not Diagnostics which are
officially to an officially approve
biomarker and also a corresponding
treatment and those companion
diagnostics they should ensure the safe
and effective use of a product so final
treatment and they can be differentiated
between in vitro and imaging
technologies and they are either clear
or approved by the FDA in USA and the
idea behind the companion diagnostics is
you can see on the right picture again
we have a patient population and for
this patient populations biomarker
Diagnostics takes place and each
different patient populations receives a
unique therapy based on their biomarker
Diagnostics respectively based on their
genetic profile so and those patients
are most likely to benefit from the
treatment without or with really less
adverse events and mmm the old structure
or the old strategy of treatments was we
have just a patient population the big
one and they receive all one therapy and
then we have patients who would benefit
who had no benefit or in the worst case
with adverse events
and the companion diagnostics market has
its aim to transform the left side into
the right side and that's the ID on
behind and the same with the biomarkers
we have already established companion
diagnostic technologies the most common
or used one is the moon is two chemistry
which is used for example for estrogen
receptors
prova strong receptors and EGFR in
breast cancer like in the picture I've
shown before also the fluorescence in
situ hybridization is used for example
to determine ALK and non small cell lung
cancer and also the more of molecular
techniques like quantitative real-time
pcr which is used for determining
bcr-abl one in chronic myeloid leukemia
and also and this is what my
presentation is aiming for the NGS the
upcoming technology and companion
diagnostics because this can data mine
and detailed genomic profile measuring
insertions or deletions copy number
alterations microsatellite instability
to a mutational burden in different
tumor entities nowadays an NS plc breast
cancer ovarian cancer searcy and also in
melanoma so here you can see NGS plays a
very important role in the clinical
ecology because NGS is rapidly evolving
and it enables the molecular profiling
of individual patients furthermore it
enables the identification of genomic
driver alterations in cancer which is
normally utilized by whole genome
sequencing and it enables multiplex
essays we can we can sequence different
samples in one run and so the
parallelization is given NGS and also
one big advantages requires just low
simple amounts for example down to 50
nano gram DNA which is really important
in the clinical samples especially if we
take into consideration the FFPE samples
there they have normally a very low
amount of DNA and also low quality but
Angie has made it feasible to sequence
those samples quite straightforward and
so the importance of NGS in clinical
oncology is also reflected in the
clinical trials model so we have the
past models of clinical trials normally
starting with eligibility assessment and
the randomization of the patients and
then we have to cause with a control
therapy and a test therapy and finally
you at the endpoint endanger analysis
and the compares and the NGS the
prospective NGS model in clinic oncology
offers new opportunity at first after
resecting two more and NGS eligibility
assessments will take place and then we
can distinguish the therapy a and even
if we have no response
the original NGS data can be realized
and again assessed for the Indians
therapy NGS based therapy and then we
can apply the therapy B for these
patients recurrence takes place after
therapy a
NGS offers the analysis of the
recurrence ID and then subsequently
assessment for the next therapy and then
we can give a combination of UPA + B and
also the same for occurrence of
metastasis the metastasis can be
analyzed by sequencing and again assess
for for the next therapy so we have much
more freedom to tailor the treatment for
the patients with these new models or
the new years but the problem is NGS is
really strong and really fancy
technology but it still faces several
challenges which has to be overcome
before it can be become a standard tool
in the Clinical Oncology we have sample
quality issues we have regulatory
obstacles awesome consideration with
ethical issues
regarding storing all the sequencing
data they are still missing restrictive
restrictive guidelines and SEO piece we
have validation problems also quality
benchmarks are missing as well as which
is associated with a quality benchmark
we have minimum requirements for data
quality metrics and cut-offs which still
need to be defined and also the
considerations for data storage sprays a
private or role regarding the ethical
issues who owns the data for example and
the solution or the possible solution to
overcome these obstacles is the
standardization and harmonization of
workflows devices and so on and this is
the second part of our presentation we
can distinguish between crucial parts in
NGS which need to be standardized this
can be differentiated between upstream
and downstream part so in the upstream
part we have the sample transport
storage extraction of the sample and so
on and this is interesting so we have to
think out of the box because
standardization already starts much
before the sample is in the lab actually
the sample transport does does a
transport company does do they store the
sample properly do they have the right
temperature standards need to become
defined for this part now also after the
extraction after the analysis then we
have the downstream parts everything
which happens after the sample has been
sequenced so the data processing as we
standardize the annotation and also the
storage of the sequencing results so
those both upstream and downstream
pipeline those are parts of the
workflows of an NGS and then we also can
distinguish between tangible and
intangible standards so standard
definition for devices or for kids or
for regions for example by comparing
diagnostics which methods should be used
for this and this tumor entity there has
to become there is the need to define
standards and also the intangible
standards which is a bit more
complicated so metrics quality metrics
minimum thresholds cut-offs and
parameters for example the minimum
quality per base call this is an example
and Judah to just give give some
suggestions for possible standards and
de facto standards they are already
already some suggestions present or
nowadays
so here's not here's again shown the
typical sequencing workflow so beginning
with preparing a sequencing library and
preparing and enriching the template the
sequencing and the final data analysis
and all parts of those workflows they
can be subdivided into sub steps for
example in the step of preparing
sequencing library we have to control
the input at the beginning so once a
sample right we've to tangle oh what's
in that sample which amount and which
quality and for this there is the need
to determine the quality control
checkpoints for example using the
spectrophotometer
or a capillary electrophoresis and also
standard values or minimum quality
metrics for the data generated by those
QC checkpoint appliances for example you
can see a down there there's a typical
electropherogram so the result of a
capillary electrophoresis analysis and
most commonly uses the Rin they're on a
integrity number for RNA samples and
there's a quality value we can where we
have an idea about the quality of our
RNA sample and standards need to be
defined for this value for example and
also which is really interesting and
plays a very important role our
reference materials it's actually
reference materials for validation of
dancing experiments and sequencing
platforms and here on the right you can
see one possible reference material this
is a genome of the bacteriophage vx1 for
174 and actually a reference material in
NGS experiments is nothing less there's
a then a very well known and very well
characterized DNA sample which is
carried along the entire sequencing
workflow and undergoes the same handling
steps like the original sample and the
idea behind the reference sample is that
any final data analysis if error
occurred in the reference sample which
is well characterized then the same are
all cured in all likelihood in the main
sample and so then we have to think
about which further steps we should take
and so this is also a very important
strong tool for objective comparison
between different sequencing platforms
mmm and finally and the data analysis
pipelines only downstream part and
there's also the need for a definition
of minimum quality metrics for the data
analysis so for example the depth of the
coverage or the average coverage
especially the death of the coverage
this is very crucial in clinical
application we need a high coverage but
which coverage is high what should be a
standard value for the depth the
coverage also the distribution or the
uniformity of the coverage and the
percentage of mapped reads and ever and
the Evert read length the adapter rate
the mapping quality also the GC content
of the sample decline in signal
intensity and the minimum quality scores
for the base calling so if you receive
our fast you files we have the the phred
quality scores so per base the quality
score but what should be the new norm
minimum requirement for lowest quality
scores and those questions
we're already present in for some people
in the United States who set up
standardization of fourths so
initiatives have been found and we're
discussing those questions which I've
mentioned before and so they are already
several stimulation of force in energy
as present so let's start just with an
overview the NGS guidelines for the
somatic genetic Brian detection which
are published by the New York State
Department of Health
which contains the same characteristics
like published in the clinical
laboratory Improvement Amendment get
lines so those are already quite good
known and a lot of laboratories are
certified by prior and those guidelines
include validation parameters or
performance characteristics as it just
turned by the Kleier
so minimum requirements for accuracy
robustness precision repeatability
reproducibility analytical sensitivity
and specificity as well as reportable
and risk reference range and furthermore
they offer also suggested proposals for
reference materials for the quality
control sequencing experiments those
same what I've mentioned before they
have made a suggestion for establishment
of three different controls the North
template control the negative control as
well as the positive or sensitivity
control hmm furthermore there is the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology the genome in a bottle
consortium probably a lot of people also
know this consortium they wanted to
investigate reference data on methods
and standards for next-generation
sequencing and they proposed the use of
welcome characterized whole genome
sequences as reference materials and
furthermore they wanted to go more into
detail for the use of reference but use
or methods for reference at use in order
to understand the performance of
different energy systems then we have
the
of biomolecular resource facilities
especially the NGS workgroup mmm they
also worked on similar topics like the
identification of optimal methods and
strategies for NGS projects and also the
performance a variation between
different NGS platforms so in order to
compare different platforms in their
performance then one of my favorite
workgroups they have published a very
comprehensive paper about accreditation
checklist requirements this was
published by the College of American
Pathologists and those this publication
includes several detailed standard
proposals amongst others for
documentation validation Quality
Assurance and so on so also or or a lot
of topics which are necessary for
accreditation of laboratories for
example then furthermore furthermore to
come back to the reference materials
there was already one consortium which
actively develop RN a spike in controls
for NGS experience that's the ERC see
the external RNA control consortium so
and then we have the genomic standards
consortium which has published the
minimum information about genome
sequence specification and their aim was
to remedy the lack of in complete genome
descriptions for data submission so now
we are deep in the downstream power of
NGS experiments so once all analysis
have been accomplished then the
submission of the data to prop two
databases is the next step and there's
still the problem that a lot of data
gets published without proper
descriptions and therefore the GS cm IGS
they proposed to you to include and
those data also the DEF coverage the
overt quality
the taxonomy the trophic level and the
propagation as a minimum requirement for
the submission of sequencing data then
we have the micro a quality control
project and especially phase three of
this project sequencing quality control
this is really interesting because they
also evaluated the technical performance
between different NGS platforms by
establishing benchmarks with reference
samples so what I've also thought before
been a quiet old initiative the human
genome project they have published the
Buddhist and maths actually and those
are standards for sequence fidelity and
those were one of the first to publish
an actual value and actually quality
value as a standard proposal the Q 40 so
the quality value in the data analysis
or 99.99% accuracy or one hair of ten
thousand base pairs they said that
should be the minimum quality
requirement for for sequencing
experiments and then finally was a very
interesting approach and initiative of
the next-generation sequencing
standardization of clinical testing
workgroup they also published a very
comprehensive publication dealing with
principles guidelines standards and
recommendations for the implementation
of NGS into diagnostic laboratories so
actually exactly this one which is
interesting for precision medicine
approaches especially for
standardization of NGS in precision
medicine and furthermore they have
published a novel NGS proficient
proficiency testing system which enables
an error identification which is
associated with an FMEA but what this is
I will come I will go into more detail
later on and the indication of QC
problems so quality control problems and
this PT system also enables the
verification of test performance in
laboratories so was a very nice approach
however so if we have seen there a lot
of difference
initiatives already present so already a
lot of work was done but which was still
an obstacle as a lack of documentation
so we have standard proposals we have
have proportions for quality metrics but
the documentation or the quality this is
also an issue which is not addressed
nowadays so there's a need to develop
procedure operating inspection
instructions respectively SOPs and also
the establishment of quality records
respectively verification documents for
quality proof of data is needed and
those quality records once developed are
also suitable for providing a quality
certificate to the customer that
customer knows ok the sequencing
experience was of high quality so I can
rely or I can trust in those results and
one possible approach to establish such
a quality documentation is the
establishment of a technical note in
order to improve the overall quality
documentation and this is actually a
piece of paper just carry along the
entire sequencing workflow and this
enables the traceability of error of
errors and this is also associated with
the FMEA which I will go into teacher
later on and the accreditation checklist
requirements which were published by the
College of American Pathologists
and actually a TM is carried along the
entire workflow as I said and on each
different QC checkpoint the TM has to be
filled by the questions who what when
where why and how
why clock for example let's take the
fragmentation step in a sequencing
workflow so the processing of the sample
the TN asked for who is fragmenting the
sample so that we have a name what
samples fragmented so for example which
order number for which project when was
the sample fragmented so time and day
also necessary to know where what said
assemble fragmented so for example in
which laboratory or in which department
why was the simple fragmented so this is
also again or the number so that we can
trace the way back to the original
sample and the most important point how
was the sample fragmented so which
device was used or which appliance so
what were the minimum quality
requirements for for this processing
step hmm and so this represents a
certificate for each step waken where or
a quality certificate for the customer
that he knows exactly okay what happens
was the sample by and how and there's a
need to establish something like this an
NGS experiments so and from quality
management if I tell if a or if I'm tell
you about quality management I also have
to mention the Quality Assurance which
which is a crucial part of the quality
management and now finally I come to the
FMEA which is actually Quality Assurance
method and this is really a really
interesting method actually mmm the FMEA
it's just a failure mode and effects
analysis and there's a standard methods
in preventive quality and risk
management and you can you can perceive
it as a schematic method to recognize
and evaluate existing and possible
errors and then finally to determine
adequate measures for avoiding these
errors and that means actually you
analyze the arrows before they are here
this is important in energy as
experience because if a sample gets
failed you have to start from the
beginning and it also enables the
classification of arrows so actually
what is an error in angeas that's
important to define and I put this
picture here or the NASA moon mission
in this slide because this is very
interesting the FMEA or rich in aids
actually from the neza it was so FMEA
was developed prior of the moon mission
in order to determine and classify all
arrows which could occur during the moon
actually the sense behind this is one
error happens there's there's no way you
have only one way to the moon and one
way back so you have to classify and
collect all possible rows and define
them and define measures or instructions
what happens after the error occurred
and this shows the importance of this
too and actually this could be also
applied in NGS experiments but maybe not
such as comprehensive such in the moon
missions and yeah how does it work if
MEA requires that far as a comprehensive
process analysis and you have to collect
all possible our courses in NGS
workflows so what are for example some
possible error costs a wrong operation
of devices or also a beer of devices of
all devices unsuitable analysis
processes or defective regions or old
regions unsuitable temperatures doing
the NGS workflows and so on so so lists
can be continued infinitely I think
there are so many possible error courses
in NGS experiments and so this is the
comprehensive process analysis and after
that after you've identified all arrows
you can make these adequate measures or
instructions or avoiding these roles and
the idea behind this the FMEA is based
on the rule of 10 so that means the cost
for troubleshooting performed by
correction measures increases tenfold in
each stage so and that's because the
idea of the FMA to avoid these errors or
to classify these errors before they can
appear so
that they don't you and this is
evaluated mathematically by the RPM
that's the risk priority number and this
is calculated by the probability of an
arrow occurrence time the M times the
impact or extent of an arrow times the
probability of the error detection and
dependent on the number which will
result out there you have a very
detailed classification of an error and
you know in which stages of a workflow
have to be I would say very tiny to
avoid these errors so and that's
actually all unfortunately time is not
enough to talk about everything what I
like to talk but just give some more
recommendations what is to do or give
some hints and some suggestions for
future activities I wanted to mention
some points on my last slide so the next
steps would be also which are necessary
would be standardization of the patient
evaluation and the electronic and
medical records or how they are called
nowadays the electronic health records
especially in consideration of the
sequencing data storage so probably
patients 2 more profile gets sequence so
where do we store those data are they
are in the EMR or EHR or databases so
this is a point where we have to think
about also the EMR or ER EHR linkage to
laboratory results and across health
systems is a point which need to be
discussed in the future then obviously
the standardization of clinical practice
guidelines when NGS is established into
a clinical trials this is an important
point and of course the consensus
finding by infrequent expert panels who
are specialized on precision medicine
it's crucial point so we have to build a
foundation where all stakeholders can
discuss about all those issues find a
consensus
and to find finally standards regulated
standards in the end then also very
important point yeah biomarker and
companion diagnostics validation is
important so therefore there's need to
establish routine inter laboratory tests
so example using sequencing the same NGS
regimen with different appliances and
different laboratories so validation
concepts are also one point which is
necessary in the future and also the
awareness amongst all precision medicine
stakeholders so those fairness has to be
raised it has to be discussed it has to
be marketed so information has to be
shared and everyone who is associated
with with the precision medicine knows
about the up-to-date information and
what is possible and what is not
possible then quite simple but
nevertheless important point the
terminology so there's also the need to
define official precision medicine
terminology definitions so what is a
biomarker what is a companion
diagnostics what is precision medicine
itself and for example the I saw where I
was involved in they have one workgroup
which are still worth with definitions
terminology definitions and
biotechnology so we need official
definitions in order to get clarity
around around this field and the last
point quite fancy terms which are curing
nowadays quite frequently we have to
keep observe the developments and
artificial intelligence and the digital
ones but this is another big chapter
which I have not discussed right now so
I'm at the end thank you very much for
your attention and if you have any
suggestions if anything is unclear or
you just would like to discuss
feel free to drop me an email or write
me on LinkedIn thank you very much and
take care Thank You Christophe for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar so if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box it appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started the first
question is is it better to define one
general standard or multiple standards
for NGS applications in precision
medicine that's a good question so it
depends on the application actually one
generalist and not only one would be
obviously more advantageous do to better
comparability of results and just
because of these the NewsAsia
environments that we have not so much
standards however one general standard
would not be feasible at the moment to
do to the quite young area and also
things like sample and to more
heterogeneity and different requirements
between different sequencing platforms
that's multiple standards for difference
difference regimen will become developed
in short to mid-term I would say and and
those standards once established it
could become revised or harmonized in
long term developments I think next one
is who is or who will be responsible for
setting up standards in NGS in precision
medicine yeah this is also a good
question so as I've shown already in the
presentation there are different
standards ation and quality management
initiatives already present so within
the last years a lot of initiatives have
been found
however the regulated standard structure
this will be determined by official
bodies like the international
standardization organization the Heysel
and what I've mentioned before there's
already one Technical Committee where I
was also involved in within the Eisen
and they're advancing standardization of
force and biotechnology so this Technic
committee is called ISO TC 276
biotechnology and this technical
Commission comprises already six
different working groups and the idea is
to merge different experts together to
set up standard drafts for amongst
others bio banks analytical methods as
well as the data analysis pipelines for
NGS and further quality organizations
like the United States pharmacopoeia the
USP they are planning to set up business
plans and precision medicine so also the
so for those efforts volunteer experts
are always needed to share the expertise
and finding a consensus and finally
developing standards so I can just
recommend to get in touch if you're
interested in developing those standards
get in touch with ISO for example and
your expertise is welcome thank you okay
we have time for just one more question
will NGS advancements turn precision
medicine into personalized medicine in
the future this question corresponds to
one of my first slide where I talk about
the diff the difference between
precision medicine and personalized
medicine so just keep it back in mind
precision medicine just that our patient
stratification tailor treatments
according to environmental genetic
lifestyle of different patients and
personalized medicine one unique
treatment for one unique patients I
think regarding this question so well
and yes turn
medicine and the personalized medicine
in future probably yes but at the moment
the NGS technologies allow just a
precision medicine approach or a better
said much better patient stratification
down to smaller populations which are
most likely to benefit from a tailor
treatment based on their genetic and
genomic profiles advancements in NGS
technologies also the third generation
technologies so bio Oxford nanopore also
the biomarker discoveries and the
developments in the companion
diagnostics and also the future
standardization and harmonization of
thoughts will likely turn precision
medicine into personalized medicine I
said tailor treatments for each and my
opinion I think this will still need
along quite a long time because also
standardization is a long process and
but the future is open well thank you I
would like to once again thank Christoph
Angela for his presentation what also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcasts possible
before I go on I let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through September 21st
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye